Hello Everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Subnautica.
Now I had to come all the way back to the base
because for some reason when you eat too much of the same fish
your health gets cut in half.
Also I wanted to read the names on the locker.
The first one goes to
Sara Sabbaaaa: "Well you can tell that stuuupid Reaper Leviathan that it can bing-bong bring it on,"
which is a reference to
SCP Containment Breach, oddly enough, from a long time ago.
But thank you so much Sara.
And then,
and this one just made me laugh.
Anger Wagon just said "The Anger Wagon is pleased"
which i'm assuming is good? I have no idea?
Did my rage compilation please the Anger Wagon?
So Anger Wagon...
And then, uh, Clancy Ireland, who said "I was so scared when he went in the hole."
Which is oddly topical to what I'm about to do now
and know that I-I'm still recording from the last time, so know
i-it's kind of the same recording, but it does take place in the same realistic scenario here,
and what's going to happen is...
Wow
I did not know that my Cyclops had that much of a light on it.
But what I'm gong to do is- I'm actually gonna take my Cyclops
One, because
the USS "Fuck the Ocean" hasn't had much use lately but also,
because it charges up,
Wow, I don't have a lot of power
Hang on, I think I actually have a power cell on me
Because It also charges up my Seamoth and this is kinda far away and I wanna make sure I don't run out
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE OCEAN, because that has happend before
where my Seamoth just kinda - dies.
In the middle of nowhere, and it's stranded forever and I don't wanna do dat.
So I'm not gonna do that
but this thing is as slow as shit
So I'm just going to meander my way across the o- I wonder if I can breach with this thing?
Haaaaaa!
Holy shit!
*laughs* I didn't know my Cyclops was that agile!
Hiiiiiidaaaaah!
I'm gonna ram it
I'm gonna ram my- uhhh maybe it's not a good idea to ram my life boat
But maybe I'm just gonna try and act like a humpback whale and just kinda breach over it
And just totally capsize it
I mean if it collapses under the weight of a single human standing on the top of it,
which it did in the last episode,
I wonder what an entire boat's gonna do to it?
Haaabuaaaah
Ooops
Sorry!
Aah shit, I'm sorry
I wanna do it again kinda but I gotta- I got a mission to complete.
Don't try to bug me.
I also don't know where I'm going
Okay I'm assuming it's this way but I'm not a hundred percent sure
Like you- you wouldn't think it'd be so hard to find a giant hole in the ground
but
Markiplier doesn't know his ass from a hole in the ground
So I guess it works out- That was a stupid joke, that was the stupidest joke I've ever told...anyway
moving on
*blows whale-like horn* Ohhh! I have a horn?!
*blows horn again* I didn't know I had a horn! Did I know I have a horn?
I don't even remember doing the horn
*blows it again* YAY! Cyclops ahoy! The USS "Fuck the Ocean" is here to stay.
*And he blows it again* Take that Sancho
*And again* This is just gonna beckon all the Leviathans to my direction.
It's gotta be- I gotta be like
I gotta be like above it right?
I can only go so deep in this thing
And I don- I really would rather not ram anything
What is that? What is that?
I can't even tell what tha- Oh I am in the mushroom forest.
Okay so I'm generally in the right area
I can probably get out the Seamoth pretty soon here
*blows horn and yells* Aarrrgh
Okay I think we're good
Alright, this should be pretty close
I need to hop out anyways so that I can see exactly where I am
So into the Seamoth, here we go!
Boopity boob boop boobpity boop
Here we go, the "Fuck-A-Duck" is out and about
Alright! Where we at?
Ooh, were we close?
Ooh, I think we were close!
Ah, am good!
Alright, bye bye baby! Bye bye Keith,
you be good I'm gonna go adventure
into some places where I shouldn't go,
probably. Because I hate going in giant holes
in the ground- what is that? Oh, that's the other
wreckage! Okay so that's the wreckage, it was
just to the right of that... And so is a
Leviathan, but we're gonna ignore that!
We're gonna pretend like that's not a
problem until it's already eating me
Ooh, ah, here we go. No- yes, yeah! This is it. Okay, so, the only weird thing about this is: I've never
seen anything like it, and I just want to
get to the bottom of it. It went pretty deep-
Ooh, agh, that feels wrong, oh god. Ah, god that feels wrong! Why does it keep spinning me around like- Hello! Why are you still falling? We're
still falling! Oh, god! Ugh! Ah, why does it look like a bunch of turds, plastered all over the
walls? Why does it look like eggs? Eggs and/or turds, either one...Either one. Oh, aw! Is that it? No.
Aw, was that- Damnit!
Really!? Just looks like a bunch of lava
flow, so this must be one of the inert
lava places.
Oh hello, wait a minute! Whoa...
Whoa, what the hell is you? Why are there giant tumours, growing out of the walls here? Oh my god, are these
just gonna explode into lava and then blast me into oblivion?
Not that death means a lot in Subnautica, but- oh my god. Oh, we're still going down! I thought
we were going sideways! Holy shit! What the
frick? Oh, ooh, ooh! Maybe! Oh, this might be it!
Ooh! Oh, hello!
Man, it just- it's so big that it keeps loading in different areas. Oh, damnit. I mean, we're still going down!
*Computer voice: Caution, passing safe depth*
Oh shit! Oh
shit! We're like- This is, like, the lowest I've ever
seen any feature in Subnautica besides,
like, the end of the game drop-offs where it
actually doesn't work anymore. This is weird. Hello. Oh my
god, oh my god, we're lateral to it! We're like- we're like in line with it! This is the place!
*Computer voice: Warning! maximum depth reached.*
Oh, Sorry! Jesus! I-
I DIDN'T KNOW I COULD GET DOWN THAT FAR!
I didn't even know it was POSSIBLE! I can go farther down?!
What the FRICK?!
And this isn't like -this isn't like, you
know, "Oh this is where the game supposed
to be." This is all real! This is all put in here, this is all like a- this is like a lava formation.
This is a volcanic activity
place like this was intentionally
designed by the developers so this- this is a pla- oh my god hello. Hi!? What are you doing here?
What do you have in you?
What is in you?
Limestone outcrop? Oh, copper? Oh that's nothing. Okay maybe just maybe this isn't supposed to be
here but- Oh, there's more...
Why?
Why are you- who would come down here for copper and titanium? But it's- *gasps*
OH SCHTHIT!
This is the one, this is- this is literally it. I'm-
I'm really spitting a lot!
Also, I'm like half terrified because-
This might be where like the sea- oh...
Hang on a second, let's back up a little bit..... Why did that happen?
Ohohokay?
Why is that do that?
Why is this do this?
Why did that do that? Did I pass over a biome up above and whoa...
Ah.
*Computer voice: Warning, maximum depth reached*
Oh no.
Oh, what am I supposed to do? Am I supposed to get out?
AW! I don't want to get out!
Oh my god.
I gotta get out. Oh Shhhhhhit dude!
But it's right there!
Oh my god! Ugh! UGH! What are those?
What is that?
It's right there!
Oh, I can go up! Oh, okay,! Okay, so what I'm gonna to do is- Oh, I think I can do this.
I just need to go down and then I need to go back up before everything blows up.
Like my Seamoth, and *giggles* my lungs. No not that.
I need to actually weld it. So I need to fix it up and then when it goes down below maximum
depth,  it'll damage a bit but I can get
over to the other side, I believe anyway.
MAKE OR BREAK HERE WE GO. YOLO.
Ohhh boy, this ain't gonna be good.
*Computer voice: Hull damage imminent*
I know, I know, I know. But it's right there!
IT'S RIGHT THERE!
*excited Markimoo noises*
Oh god come on!
EEHHHHHH. Heh. EHHHHHH.
Okay, COME ONNNNNNN.
UP (X10?)
Annnnnd there we go, okay.
Oh my god, it's right there.
*Panicked/Excited screaming*
Come on, we're fine. Okay.
Oh my god. It is literally .. RIGHT THERE.
It's right there, I can swim to that!
I can swim to that.
Stop spinning in a goddamn circle!
Stop doing that!
Okay, I can swim to that. I'm gonna keep it right here,
I'm gonna repair, first off, just in case I need to
make a quick getaway with whatever the
hell is here. Might be nothing, might be something.
I FOUND IT! I FOUND IT!!
Okay, lemme just get enough oxygen because my oxygen doesn't last very long down here. Okay.
That is so weird. This is a pillar of lava.
*whispering* Oh that's so cool.
Okay. Here we go. Go. Go go go. Go go go.
"Possible cave opening." "Possible?!" I'm in the world's biggest cave and you wanna call it "possible."
*High pitched* What?
Okay so this is...
Thi- this is it! This is it.
Oh my god. Eug- EUGH I DON'T LIKE IT. LET ME BACK IN. I WANT BACK.
*panicked Markimoo sounds*
I WANT MY MOMMY! AHHHH I WANT MY MOMMY!
*Not so brave giggling*
Oh that's so weird!
How am I supposed to be able to go
deeper though? There's stuff down there!
There's something down there!
I can't go down! I'm at maximum depth! Even my Cyclops can't get this far down.
That's so weeeeird!
I wanna risk it! I wanna go down there, but I don't have enough welding power.
Oh my god.
Which way is up? Which way did I come from?
Oh my god, I'm getting so lost in here. What is this place?!
It's like the ceiling of the world!
It's like what Atlas would hold up on earth!
Eugh, it's just bulbous!
Just bulbous ballsacks!
Pushing out- what is that?!
Why is there a rectangular formation underneath- what is this?!
What is any of this?! Am I ever gonna be able to get outta here?!
I don't think I will.
Where are we and why is this here?
Ohhhh gooood gooolly.
Is that the ground? I hope so!
In what way would I be able to do any of this?!
Is this where- like, I am genuinely concerned that I'm going to meet a giant sea creature down here,
and it's gonna be the scariest thing I've ever seen!
Like how do we know these things don't exist? Th- these things, these giant, underground caverns...
in the ocean? Like huuuuuuuuuuge.
Oh it's massive! Where does that go?!
Well I dunno!?
"Possible cave opening," my ass! You didn't tell me that the Ear- the- the planet that we're in is hollow!
(Fascinated Markimoo sounds)
I can't- I can't go there, can I?
Oh this is gonna be bad.
Eh.
Kinda? Okay. Just a little bit.
Oh my god, it's more?!
Oh it's just endless!
*Computer voice: Caution, mild dehydration detected.*
OH SCREW THE DEHYDRATION!
I'm having a luci- what are these?!
What're these, the steps to the Underworld?
What the hell is this?
*laughs*
I'm sorry! I've just been babbling nonsense for the past 10 minutes because
what the hell, have I gotten myself into? This is...
baloney.
This is... bonkers!
This is so weird!
Ah shit- oh no I'm fine.
(quiety) Oh what i-
Did you guys hear that?
You guys heard that right?
(quietly) What was that?
It's like a crevasse here! Oh my god I
can't go down it!
I can't go down this! Oh there's a bottom!
Ah shit!
Shit, shitty, shit!
Oh this is so weird!
Why is this is-? What're y-? Ohh what is th-? *laugh* Okay enough of that.
(quietly) We're gonna go-
(normal) What can I say about this? What can I say?
What is thaaaat?!
Why does it do that?! What is that?
Why am I headed towards the heat signature?
The heat signature are the steam vents on the other- on the other side of the map!
Does this thing-? Like this underground cave? Cavern?
This underground... bigger than a cave, bigger than a cavern, bigger than any of that.
This underground...
(quietly) What the fuuuuuuuuuuck?
What thE FUUUUUUUUDGE?!
I'm sorry, I'm, uh, okay, I'mma reel it in a little bit, but this is absolutely blowing my mind right now because this is-
Okay let me put it in perspective of why I'm so amazed by this.
This cavern...
If- if I'm right about this...
This goes all the way to the other side
of the map, and I'm pretty sure I'm right because
I'm pretty close to that heat signature here, and I'm slowly climbing in depth...
That means that underneath everything that we've been playing on this entire time is an entire, different world!
There they are! That- th- that's the thing! That's the Grand Reef! That's on the other side of the map!
My Cyclops, which may be pingin' from over there, is literally on the oTHER SIDE OF THE FRICKIN'
WOOOOOORLD RIGHT NOW.
What the fuuuuuudge!?
WHAT THE FUUUUUCK? How do I get outta here? Can I get outta here?!
Please tell me there's a way to get outta here?
I mean if- if I'm looking at these things there's gotta be a way to get outta here right?
There's already creatures! THERE'S LAVA!
Oh god, hello! What the frick are you? What was that?
Hello! Someone was shootin' a fireball- OH MY GOD!
THAT'S SO COOOOOOL!!!
AND SCARY!!!
It's so "scool" [cool] it's- it's "scury" [scary].
It's "s-cool-ary" [combination of "cool" and "scary."]
(to the tune of "Space Is Cool") Oh that's soooo scaaaaarrrrry! So scaaaaaaarrrrryyyyyy!
My brain can't handle the size of it.
Oh my god.
So when I was- I think I was in these caves before when I was over in this area and I was looking for this thing.
If I had I just made the right turn- yeah I can get outta here!
Yeah if I had made the right turn...
I would've ended up in this cave and going in here...
Or maybe I went in here and I didn't have enough depth, and I couldn't go all the way through?
That is...
BALONEY!
Yeah! The vents are right there! This is bonkers!
That is... bonkers.
That means- and what that means is that when the developers finally flesh that area out, they're going to have,
like literally, twice the entire size of the entire map,
available there.
And I bet down in those caverns they're probably not done yet.
They're probably not done, but there's, like, formations there at the bottom.
There- someone went in there and they made that just to taunt people, just to tantalize me.
BOOSH BABY!
I thought it was night time!
What the hell?!
Okay
I'm gonna stop freaking out because it's probably getting really old here.
Like me just constantly-  but this, like- this is so cool. This is what I was talking about in the last episode! Like,
I can explore this place, and I can see...
like just new things everywhere I go. Every single place I go, I can see new things. And that is just...
bonkers about this game. It's so cool.
Okay. Anyway, I'm gonna stop freaking out about that. I can't believe I dedicated a whole episode to just me
freaking out about this stupid cave.
But that cave was not stupid! It was more!
Oh man...
That was awesome.
Wow, what- what the hell is going on here with the island?
I don't- wasn't there a beach over here?
Wasn't there a way to get on?
I don't remember there being all like this.
Aw man.
But anyway,
that's all the time I got for this episode and it's getting to night. In the next episode, I promise you by the time you
come back, I will be in the process of building...
my new island retreat, here on the island
that you guys said I should name but...
I'm not good with coming up with names on the fly. I didn't think about this ahead of time.
Um...
"Bubblebutt Island?"
"Fumblebub?"
"Big Titty Island?"
I don't know. I can't come up with names, so you guys try to come up with names. I'll vote the best one
from the comments. You guys decide what I'm gonna name my island.
So thank you everybody- we FINALLY FOUND IT, YOU BITCH! You stupid asshole! You possible cave opening!
Talk about the most misleading signal in the history of forever!
You had to go into it from exact opposite sides of the entire frickin' map. It was in the center of the exact
bottom portion of the- goddamnit but I found you.
Oh f- oh god dehydration. Do I have water?
I do not. I'm gonna die.
Well shit. Anyway that's the end of this episode, and this is the end for me so,
thank you everybody so much for watching! Once again let me know what should name my island. And,
write a comment to see if you can get your name on a locker. I'll have new lockers for the island so thank you again.
And as always, I will see you... in the next video!
BUH BYEEE!
*Outro playing: 'Crazy La Paint'*